welcome to the technology Tuesday today
I'm answering a question for one of my
YouTube viewers love you guys
James Fraley who wrote in the say I've
been great tutorial thank you quick
question how do I save a PDF that does
not scan to a notebook with an Evernote
your offense being able to save travel
info and your vacation notebooks this is
a great question it's actually pretty
simple to do I find it really helpful
because if you get any kind of PDF
document if it's your travel itinerary
if it's a book that you downloaded that
you want to have to your Evernote so
that when you're traveling on the go you
can just pull it up on your phone or on
your laptop and it's synced offline you
have instant access to it it's super
easy to do I'm gonna hop over to my
computer and show you how to do it so
it's a pretty easy process I've loaded
Evernote up I'm just gonna add a new
note and I'm gonna name it so say I just
bought a new e-book I bought the I both
azúcar passion guide so called pseudo
passion 101 then all you have to do is
go to your Windows Explorer find the PDF
click on it and drag it in and it's
going to bring the whole PDF document in
this is a 60 page PDF it's all here that
I can browse through page at a time and
it'll be available on my computer on my
phone on my laptop anywhere where I have
ever known that's it pretty simple I
hope that helped James great question
those you watching if you like the video
you can subscribe to the channel click
on the link below believe thank you so
much and I'll see you soon don't forget
to sign up for my free newsletter its
energy in your inbox every single week
hi I'm Jason Grif on sigur rós
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period